have a look down here does anyone
recognize this
it actually has this this has a special
name
and i want you to think back to last
year this
is capital letters the binomial
theorem if you have a look at it this
thing on the left hand side it's a
binomial
right x plus a you should take the q now
by the way write it down if you haven't
already
we're raising it to some integer power m
so it's like x plus a
cubed or x plus a to the power of 17
whatever it happens to be okay now the
binomial theorem
states that if you expand this what you
will get
is this series of terms this binomial
expansion right
where you have an x term x to the n
minus r
an a term a to the r and then you'll
have what do we call that thing
in the brackets it's got a special name
this thing
yeah it comes from permutations and
combinations this particular
object we call the binomial coefficient
and actually this is the exact
context in which you see why it's called
the binomial coefficient because it's in
front of all these
x's and a's and that kind of thing by
the way that's not the only way to write
it what's our other way of
writing it it's on your calculator ncr
the c stands for choose or for
combination and
not that you need it but because it's
been a while can you remember
we actually have a definition for this
this is shorthand for a particular
fraction can anyone help me remember
what fraction
it is do you want to give us the
numerator
n factorial on the top i'll give you a
clue there's two factorials
on the bottom what are they any takers
susie what are you thinking
r factorial and then
fantastic n minus ah okay
now i'm gonna give you a big fat clue in
fact i'm gonna give you two
okay i'm gonna ask you to set out trying
to prove this just like we did
here okay but here come the two clues
right i'm gonna leave you entirely to
your own devices queen number one
sort of already said it this factorial
notation here
it's quite long right it takes something
dramatically simple
and it expands it out you do absolutely
need to know
what's behind the binomial coefficient
but for this proof
just to save you some time you actually
don't need to know
what it is right you don't need to
expand everything out into factorials
to prove this result by induction
there's my first clue
here comes my second clue if you didn't
have
factorials and all that business right
how would you get these numbers
like suppose i said to you oh i want i
really want to know what uh
4c3 is what would you do because you
actually can do it without any
calculator or anything like that
yeah you draw pascal's triangle right
now pascal's triangle
starts off uh fairly easy to draw right
this is one of the first things that i
always
drew or wrote out at the start of my
extension one exam right because i was
like
i can call call it really quickly right
so 4c3 what does it mean
well we go down to the fourth row which
one's that
it's a bit weird isn't it we call this
guy we call it the zeroth row
the zero throw by the way the reason why
we called the zeroth row
makes sense because of the binomial
theorem think about what happens when n
equals zero n equals zero you got x plus
a
you raise to the power of zero what do
you get you're this
right then you go to the next one the
the first row of pascal's triangle
this is x plus a to the power of one
here's your x
here's your a you're following okay so
here's the zeroth row here's the first
row
second third you actually just follow
these guys here the actual numbers that
change
right so the fourth row you can see
which one it is here we are
this is the fourth row which one is 4c3
it's the six or is it
look again four zero now remember it was
a clue right
i said this is a zeroth row these ones
over here
are the zeroth position on the row
weird right um by the way this is one of
the reasons why we say zero factorial
has to equal one number one uh because
if you had zero objects oh sorry let me
start again if you had three objects
how many ways can you arrange this
answer i've got three choices for the
first one then two choices then one
three times two times one if i had zero
objects in my hand how many ways do i
have to arrange them
answer one way here it is
right okay so that's the first reason
why zero factorial is one
but the other reason is to make the
binomial theorem work right if zero
factorial were not one
you'd get you'd have some major problems
on the denominator of this fraction
right so let me ask you again which term
is for c
three it's the
second four along right four c zero
four c one four c two four c three
here's the other way you can know it's
the right one the last one has to be
for c4 like if yeah does that make sense
okay
now here's finally this is me building
up right here's that second clue you'll
need
to do this proof how is pascal's
triangle
built like you've got the first five
rows now
you would you could easily build the
sixth row just by doing what
it's just addition isn't it now this is
very important what do you add
what terms do you add like for example
how did i get this 10 right here
i added the 6 and the 4 just above it
right so this term here
plus this term here will give me
this term here now we can say this we
can state this
using an identity because this is always
true no matter where you are on pascal's
triangle
these two will give you this one okay so
just as an example
here what did we say this one was we
said that was four
c three which makes the one before it
four c
two so i would say just as an example
here
that would give me number one it's on
the next row so what was top number b
maybe five because i'm in the fifth row
now which term along
am i just be careful it's term number
three
zero one two three okay so this is just
one example
can we generalize this can we generalize
it for
any particular row
what we're about to write is called
pascal's identity because it's an
identity that comes from
pascal's triangle okay there's a bunch
of different ways to state it i think
the form that will be most helpful to
you guys will be
n choose
r minus 1 this is my r minus 1. then the
next one along
same row but you go forward one
now you guys help me out all this b n
plus one because i go to the next
row i go to the next row and then
look at the numbers what's this one
going to be it'll be r okay
now i told you this was a clue right you
will absolutely need to do this
if you want to prove by induction in any
reasonable time
uh the binomial theorem okay just just
look with me before i let
let you loose right just have a look at
the structure of every proof by
mathematical induction
can you perhaps see
why an identity like this might be
immensely helpful to you when you're
dealing
with n equals k's n equal k plus ones
i know it might not be clear yet because
you'll need to get to that point
but i'm just going to put that there and
leave it there i promise you'll need it
i'm going to shut up and let you have a
go okay do the test do the assumption
and then see if you can do the k plus
one step using this guy
okay off you go